r notamment avec la crise sanitaire
ainsi internet on est moins ceux des
jaunes mystique moins religieuse comme
on peut on pouvait l'avoir 210 80 que
sur des phénomènes qui vont concerner la
santé ou l'alimentation et la crise du
coc vide à renforcer cette nouvelle
porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des gourous vont plutôt
parler de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti vaccin
contre le co lead certains éléments qui
se rattachent à des mouvements à
tendance sectaire qui historiquement
sont opposés à toute vaccination
[Musique]
la situation politique d'abord c'est
quoi votre analyse de cette espèce de
tsunami
les choses commencent à s'organiser plus
entre deux poules ou trois peut-être la
france elle est entre la droite et
l'extrême droite on peut pas éviter ce
constat la situation politique va se
passer à droite et sur des thématiques
de droite ça veut dire par exemple que
votre candidate est obligé de durcir ses
positions de droite l'idée de cette
primaire interne c'était de créer à
l'arrivée une équipe de france et
l'équipe de france elle est là c'est la
première fois première fois dans
l'histoire de france qu'une femme selon
les sondages peut être élue présidente
de la république c'est sans doute une
révolution qui permet de dire que le
plafond de verre a peut être enfin
exploser
[Musique]
à
là aussi il répondra de manière
militaire et technique aux menaces
occidentales ce sont les mots ce matin
de vladimir poutine lors d'une réunion
avec les hauts responsables du ministère
russe de la défense en toile de fond le
dossier ukrainien à washington paris
berlin et londres accusé moscou de
vouloir envahir l'ukraine est le kremlin
elle dément
[Musique]
73 mille nouveaux cas positifs
coronavirus en moins de 24 heures en
france mais le porte parole du
gouvernement s'est exprimé ce soir pour
faire un point sur la situation
el barrio mikron est particulièrement
présent et représente 20 % des cas dans
le pays le pass vaccinale devraient être
adoptées dès la première quinzaine du
mois de janvier et pour tenter
d'endiguer l'épidémie le gouvernement
pourrait prendre de nouvelles mesures
concernant la soirée du 31 décembre
et aux états unis ne variant mikron est
désormais majoritaire il représente plus
de 73% des nouvelles infections et c'est
dans ce contexte que joe biden va
s'adresser à la nation et pour être
annoncé de nouvelles mesures de
restriction ailleurs nombreux sont les
pays qui annonce le renforcement de
leurs restrictions c'est le cas pour
l'allemagne la suède ou encore la
tunisie
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez sur rt france
la réponse claire ce matin de vladimir
poutine concernant les menaces
occidentales dans le cadre des tensions
en ce moment à la frontière ukrainienne
le président russe promet d'apporter une
réponse militaire et technique si les
occidentaux ne met pas fin à leur
politique jugée menaçante les etats-unis
et l'union européenne craignent toujours
une invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
alors que moscou dément toujours l'idée
d'une intervention militaire les
dernières informations avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine gayraud
rapidement lors de son intervention le
président russe a abordé la situation
épineuse dans l'est de l'ukraine va lire
poutine alerter sur la menace que ferait
planer le déploiement d'armes
stratégiques américaines dans le
voisinage proche de la russie en
particulier en ukraine nous sommes
préoccupés de voir qu'à proximité des
frontières de la russie la force de
défense antimissile américaine ne cesse
de se développer et
avec notamment des systèmes d'armes
tomahawk
et si cela se poursuit de cette façon si
les systèmes de missiles américains
les de l'otan apparaissent
dans en ukraine ça veut dire que le
temps de vol des missiles occidentaux
jusqu'à moscou serait dur à à 5 ou 10
minutes et à cet égard et comme vous le
savez je
proposerai au président américain
de négocier sur certaines mesures très
concrètes des en réalité d'ailleurs au
cours de la discussion il a lui même
proposé de nommer des responsables pour
gérer ces
négociations et donc nous allons faire
nous continuer à faire de nos
propositions pour éviter toute extension
de l'otan et
développement d'armes offensives dans
les territoires adjacents à la
fédération de russie vladimir poutine
est ensuite quelque peu remonter dans le
temps pour constater qu'à une époque et
bien pas si lointaine russie et
etats-unis- coopérer sur de nombreux
sujets des conseillers américains
venaient même discuter avec le
gouvernement russe malgré la bonne
volonté de moscou l'otan continue son
extension vers l'est et washington
financé des groupes terroristes dans le
caucase par exemple et pour ces raisons
le président russe impute à washington
la responsabilité de la dégradation des
relations entre les deux pays il y avait
des conseillers américains qui
travaillent qui travaillent dans le
gouvernement russe et qui apporte qui
apportèrent leur conseille comme on dit
alors pourquoi encore soutenir le
séparatisme dans le caucase du nord et
encore l'état islamique
9 à papa l'état islamique mais d'autres
organisations terroristes islamistes ils
les soutenaient ouvertement pourquoi
pourquoi faire ça pour quoi agrandir
l'otan encore pourquoi cette question de
la défense antimissile
tout ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il ya
des tensions qui se mettent c'est leur
faute c'est leur faute à eux à chaque
pas la russie était bien objet de
répondre à chaque fois à chaque pas la
situation ne faisait que s'aggraver
toujours et toujours et aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans cette situation où nous
sommes obligés de prendre des décisions
on peut pas les laisser continuer à
faire dégénérer cette situation vladimir
poutine a profité de l'occasion pour
féliciter ses troupes en faisant savoir
qu'elle avait rempli toutes leurs
missions que ce soit en syrie leur
mission de maintien de la paix dans le
haut karabakh ou encore dans le cadre de
la lutte contre le coc vide 19 mai c'est
bien la position forte de vladimir
poutine sur la situation dans l'est de
l'ukraine que l'heureux tiendra à savoir
que la russie se réserve le droit de
répondre de façon militaire et technique
à toute escalade américaine en ukraine
et le nouveau chancelier allemand on
s'est dit ce soir inquiet face à la
situation en ukraine après son premier
entretien téléphonique avec vladimir
poutine est le président russe appelle
l'otan à des discussions sérieuses et
demandent des garanties de sécurité elle
son homologue ukrainien se dit lui
frustrés face aux hésitations de l'otan
et l'union européenne un volodymyr
zelensky réitère aujourd'hui la volonté
de kiev d'intégrer l'union européenne
ces prochaines années et l'otan en 2022
à l'otan n'a pour le moment fixé aucun
délai pour une éventuelle adhésion de
l'ukraine au sein de l'alliance
atlantique à et ancien ambassadeur aux
jeunes berg hauteur de la russie pour
les nuls aux éditions first estime que
cette sortie de vladimir poutine un
s'inscrit dans une logique de
pourparlers à venir avec washington et
ses alliés occidentaux
vladimir poutine
à mâcher finalement ses troupes pour se
faire entendre et ouvrir un dialogue il
l'a fait d'une manière aux yeux
d'élections tour brutal mais il dit
toujours six mois j'ose pas l'temps ne
m'écoute pas on ne négocie pas avec moi
si jo byden tient sa parole si
l'appareil américain tient sa parole il
doit faire des propositions très rapide
justement pour définir
sous quelle forme à il y aura ces
discussions les états unis les
occidentaux tentent sont pas fermes mais
à discussion simplement ils veulent se
donner le temps de négocier en train de
se concerter je crois que la priorité et
je la sens quand même une une volonté de
négocier mais avant de négocier sous un
établir le formant et ensuite lors du
jour
et fêtes approchent et la menace
sanitaire se précise à l'occasion d'une
nouvelle réunion interministérielle et
d'élus locaux le gouvernement rappelait
la menace du variant mikron et les
mesures qu'il comptait prendre pour le
contrer notamment est la transformation
du pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale la
mesure du passé ni terre en entreprise
ne devrait pas figurer dans le texte du
projet de loi alors que le calendrier
s'accélère
avec le virus le point sur les derniers
éléments avec adrien fonteneau
l'épidémie s'accélère nous accélérons
aussi dans nos mesures à la parole de
gabriella talent sont joints les actes
de jean castex prévue le 5 janvier 2022
le projet de loi sur le pass vaccinale
sera finalement présenté la semaine
prochaine d'abord en conseil des
ministres avancé au lundi 27 puis à
l'assemblée quelques jours après
objectif inciter toujours plus à la
vaccination depuis l'allocution du
premier ministre de vendredi nous avons
constaté un doublement des prises de
rendez vous pour des primo injection ce
qui est très important aussi puisque ça
nous permet d'élargir encore notre
couverture vaccinale est aujourd'hui
nous avons recensé près de 50000 primo
injection dans notre pays ce qui est un
niveau qu'il n'avait pas atteint depuis
plusieurs semaines voire même plusieurs
mois s'agissant de la campagne de rappel
nous avons dépassé aujourd'hui les 20
millions de personnes qui ont reçu un
rappel avec donc quatre jours d' avance
sur l'objectif qui avait été fixé par
olivier véran puisqu'une avait fixé cet
objectif pour noël des français qui se
vaccinent et un relâchement observé dans
les restaurants la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre et des sanctions plus
lourdes ont été demandés par l'exécutif
pour lutter face aux 180 2000 faux-pas
sanitaires un durcissement des contrôles
face à un variant moins contrôlable lui
aussi près de 73 mille cas positifs ont
été détectés hier dans notre pays ce qui
correspond à une hausse de l'ordre de
15% par rapport au lundi précédent le
taux d'incidence s'établit à 540 5 pour
cent mille habitants avec des disparités
régionales assez forte puisqu'il atteint
près de mille pour cent mille habitants
à paris au niveau national les
estimations actualisées ce soir de la
circulation du variant omicron dans
notre pays fait état de 20 % des cas
positifs qui relèverait du variant
omicron je rappelle que l'estimation qui
avait été fait en fin de semaine ce
week-end faisait état d'une circulation
de 10% dans notre pays nous voyons donc
une augmentation importante face à la
crainte de mikron et les précédents de
saturation des hôpitaux le gouvernement
veut prendre ses bonnes résolutions
avant même 2022 et le vario mikron qui
oblige ans que le gouvernement à
accélérer son calendrier pour la mise en
place du pass vaccinale à ce que déplore
justement notre éditorialiste avec ses
poulains depuis cinq ans la france et
neurasthénique on est dans un pays d'une
tristesse infinie je vous rappelle qu'on
a quand même gagné la coupe du monde qui
s'en rappellent la coupe du monde de
foot elle a été volée sur les champs
elysées il ya aucun moment de liesse de
joie hélas dès que vous avez des fêtes
on interdit le rassemblement alors on a
fermé les boîtes de nuit d'abord
maintenant on va interdire les feux
d'artifice de nouvel an on explique aux
gens commencèrent chez eux ne pas être
plus de 6 les alors le l'an dernier il
fallait laisser papy mamie sur le balcon
cette année ils ont le droit d'être là
mais au bout de la table faudrait pas
trop qui s'infectent le masque de
manière perpétuelle je crois qu'ils
pourquoi les français sont si fatigué
c'est qu'il ya une main délitement des
solidarités un délitement des moments de
joie de communes de communauté tous les
lieux de vie étaient montrés du doigt
les restaurants les les boîtes de nuit
les bars etc les théâtres mais
rappelez-vous la milice du travail qui
disait on n'attrape pas le qu'ovide au
travail bon ben maintenant on est en
train de discuter d'un pass vaccinale
pour aller travailler c'est n'importe
quoi et alors que l'hexagone fait face m
5e vague épidémique certains soignants
sont toujours dans l'attenté d'une
rémunération et ce depuis quatre mois
sont concernés des aides soignants ou
encore des kinésithérapeutes venus en
renfort durant l'été dans les hôpitaux
d'outre-mer le ministère de la santé a
déclaré s'être aperçu de cet oubli en
octobre dernier
une liste des soignants ont concerné
doit être dressé par l' agence régionale
de santé a parmi eux est clair finos
yéti elle est infirmière vacataires même
ceux qui font partie du décret pour
l'instant il y en a très peu qui ont été
payés ceux qui ont été payés c'est
souvent ceux qui sont déjà salariés
d'hôpitaux et qui ont juste reçu leur
paye comme comme s'il avait travaillé en
métropole mais voilà pas tout ce qui est
laid les 20% de crispation et 107 payer
20% plus quand on va en outre mer ni les
primes les primes liées à notre mission
ce qui m'interpelle mois ce qui
interpelle aussi mes collègues c'est
qu'en fait on a été réquisitionnée son
voile c'est vraiment le terme de
réquisition c'est à dire qu'avec ce
terme de réquisition ils peuvent nous
faire partir sans forcément de contrat
de travail donc fort sans forcément de
grille de salaires c'est à dire que par
la suite on est réquisitionné on va
travailler et ils ont tout l'opportunité
par la suite de définir selon quelle
selon quelles modalités on y va et selon
quelles modalités et on nous paie délit
est en pleine campagne de lutte contre
le variant mikron 1/5 vaccin peut être
utilisé au sein de l'union européenne
son nom nicvax ovide commercialisé par
la société américaine un produit qui
n'utilisent pas la rn messager mais une
technique plus classique dit elle sous
unités protéique les détails en images
[Musique]
novavax soutiendra les campagnes de
vaccination dans les états membres de
l'ue eux pendant une phase cruciale de
la pandémie
[Musique]
et le vario mikron donc présent en
français majoritaires royaume uni où son
premier ministre boris johnson elle fait
face à une nouvelle polémique une photo
prouverait que le chef d'état
britannique n'a pas respecté le
confinement en 2020 un nouveau coup dur
pour boris johnson hector la salle
cette photographie du journal the
guardian montre boris johnson entouré de
plusieurs collaborateurs au 10 downing
street le 15 mai 2020 à ce moment la
société britannique est confiné c'est
alors la première vague du coc vide la
publication de cette photo est une bien
mauvaise publicité pour un premier
ministre déjà en difficulté boris
johnson lui même n'a pas tardé à réagir
ces gens sont au travail il s'agit de
réunions de travail c'est là où je vis
c'est là que je travaille ce sont des
réunions de personnes au travail qui
parle de travail beaucoup de travail
donc mais peu de respect des mesures
sanitaires en mai 2020 les règles sont
strictes en grande-bretagne
distanciation de 2 mètres entre
individus et pas plus de deux personnes
de foyers différents réunis en même
temps à la publication de cette petite
bombe médiatique le 19 décembre les
opposants à boris johnson désormais
nombreux au royaume uni ont rapidement
réagi depuis le début de cette pandémie
nos employés les plus exposés on
travaillait de manière éreintante pour
que nous soyons en sécurité
cette flagrante infraction de la loi par
ce gouvernement est insultante et mais
fastes j'ai une réunion de travail
importante dans cinq minutes mais cela
ne me laisse pas tout à fait assez de
temps pour me procurer mon indispensable
bouteille de rouge comment diable végète
prise au sérieux en tant que
politicienne maintenant il y a deux
semaines l'ancien porte parole de boris
johnson allegra stratton laissé entendre
en conférence de presse qu'une fête de
noël avait eu lieu au 10 downing street
en décembre 2020 également lors d'une
période de confinement
le lendemain elle démissionner le
premier ministre britannique subit des
vents contraires la défaite des
conservateurs dans le nord europe
qu'ailleurs
la fronde de 99 députés de son camp
hostile à l'idée d'un pass sanitaire la
démission de son ancien négociateur du
breakbeat david frost suite aux mesures
anti qu'ovide chaque semaine qui passe
semble pousser un peu plus boris johnson
vers la sortie
ne variant mikron majoritaire donc au
royaume uni mais aussi aux états unis et
ce dans ce contexte et c'est dans ce
contexte que beau joe biden elle va
s'adresser dans quelques minutes à la
nation le président américain pourrait
annoncer de nouvelles mesures pour
tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie dans le
pays le plus endeuillé du monde on en
parle justement avec notre correspondant
à washington thomas bonnin
thomas bonsoir alors on disait un job
hayden doit s'exprimer dans quelques
instants à quoi peut-on s'attendre
exactement
et bien a priori selon les informations
qui circulent dans la presse américaine
on ne doit pas s'attendre à de grandes
annonces l'hypothèse d'un confinement
est écartée par la maison blanche pas
non plus de nouvelles restrictions pour
les fêtes de fin d'année en réalité
l'accent devrait être surtout mis sur la
nécessité de se faire vacciner puisque
la population américaine et couvertes
par le vaccin à hauteur de 61% c'est
inférieur à la plupart des pays d'europe
et puis l'accent devrait aussi être mis
sur le dépistage avec des moyens qui
devraient être annoncées pour mettre à
disposition de nouveaux tests notamment
500 millions d'autos test qui devrait
être délivrée à la population américaine
d'ici le mois prochain et puis on
s'attend surtout à ce que joe biden
s'adresse directement aux millions
d'américains qui ne sont toujours pas
vaccinées voici par exemple ce qu'en
disait hier la porte parole de la maison
blanche james a qui écoute et pour ceux
qui choisissent ne met pas se faire
vacciner li lanceront un avertissement
sévère et indiqueront clairement que les
personnes non vaccinées continueront à
provoquer des hospitalisations et des
décès il s'agit peut-être d'essayer de
faire comprendre les gens du pays les
risques qu'elles courent en ne se
faisant pas vacciner
alors si joe biden prend la parole ce
mardi c'est parce que la situation se
complique aux etats unis avec le variant
omicron qui est désormais majoritaire
responsable de près des trois quarts des
nouvelles contaminations dans le pays
selon les dernières données des
autorités sanitaires ici aux etats-unis
dans certains cas on assiste à une
hausse très importante du nombre de
contaminations c'est le cas par exemple
dans l'état de new york où cette hausse
s'élève à 80 % en l'espace de deux
semaines alors pour le moment les
hôpitaux américains ne sont pas
réellement saturé mais joe biden devrait
toutefois annoncer le déploiement de
1000 personnels militaires pour venir en
aide aux services hospitaliers qui en
auraient besoin joe biden qui a
d'ailleurs été en contact avec un
conseiller la semaine dernière qui a
depuis été testés positifs la maison
blanche explique que joe biden était
masqué lors de leur entretien et étant
donné qu'il a reçu sa troisième
injection et en conformité avec les
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
américaines joe biden n'a pas besoin de
s'isoler il sera donc bel et bien en
personne au pupitre de la maison blanche
d'ici quelques instants merci thomas
bonnin en direct de washington
on viendra avec vous plus tard dans la
soirée pour débriefer ensemble dans les
annonces de jobs hayden
et au liban la situation économique ne
cesse de se dégrader selon le gouverneur
de la banque centrale les réserves
nationales ont chuté de 12,5 milliards
d'euros une baisse de plus de 50% depuis
le début de la crise économique en 2019
en visite de quatre jours dans le pays
le secrétaire général de l'onu prône la
solidarité internationale et appelle à
des réformes urgentes antonio perez en a
profité pour fustiger les politiques
libanais qui l'accusent de paralyser le
pays est frappé par une crise économique
et financière sans précédent
ces deux derniers jours j'ai exhorté les
dirigeants politiques libanais à
s'efforcer de mettre en oeuvre des
réformes qui répondent aux demandes du
peuple libanais pour plus de bien-être
de responsabilité de protection et de
transparence afin de restaurer l'espoir
d'un avenir meilleur
les élections parlementaires libres et
équitables organisées dans les délais en
2022 seront une occasion essentiel pour
le peuple de faire entendre sa voix
je suis également très préoccupée par
l'impact de la crise économique et
financière dans le pays liban qui fait
que de plus en plus de personnes ont
besoin d'une aide humanitaire
un jeu dont je maison expert en
relations internationales décrit une
situation sur place est extrêmement
précaire alors que les élections
législatives au printemps prochain
pourrait redonner de l'espoir
la réalité c'est que ça n'est pas une
crise économique c'est un effondrement
économique
puisqu'en moins deux ans le produit
national brut du liban a diminué de 40 %
donc été divisée pratiquement par deux
et que la monnaie la livre libanaise a
perdu 90% de sa valeur les produits
alimentaires à beyrouth
augmenté de 2000 pour cent ce qui
explique ce que vous venez de dire dans
votre sujet à savoir que 80 pour cent de
la population par messieurs qui n'ont
pas pu s'en aller vit en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté on voit bien qu'un
certain nombre de mouvements et data etc
et que les jeunes également en place
beaucoup d'espoirs dans 107 en sélection
mais je crois qu'il faut être réaliste
keira ces élections qui va se présenter
à cette élection les partis politiques
existants de nouveaux partis politiques
peuvent en effet essayé de concourir
pour ces élections mais il s'agit
d'élire 128 députés au parlement
libanais tu es en tunisie le passé ni
terre sera obligatoire dès demain dans
les lieux et établissements publics et
les opposants à cette mesure se sont
donné rendez vous tout à l'heure devant
le tribunal administratif de tunis est
les précisions de notre correspondant
sur place kacem chebbi
des dizaines de tunisiens se sont donnés
rendez vous sur le parvis du tribunal
administratif de tunis à l'appel de
l'association coordination anti pas pour
dénoncer l'obligation du pass vaccinale
qui doit entrer en vigueur dès demain
sur l'ensemble du territoire tunisien et
étrangers depuis le 18 ans devront dès
demain présenté un pass sanitaires pour
circuler dans certains lieux publics et
infrastructures touristiques une
décision gouvernementale pour inciter
les plus récalcitrants à se faire
inoculer le sérum anti qu'ovide pour
certains tunisiens et défenseurs des
droits humains cette restriction ne
passe pas il dénonce une violation des
droits et des libertés est un impact
négatif sur l'économie tunisienne déjà
très fragilisé je vous propose de les
écouter cette loi n'a pas étudié le vrai
impact sur l'économie tunisienne
l'économie des entreprises et des
sociétés tunisiennes
elle aurait dû faire une consultation
avec les unions des travailleurs les
unions des entreprises qu'il y a dix
millions dix travailleurs qui vont
perdre leur emploi en tunisie qui va
payer
leur salaire pour leur famille pour pour
imposer les lois on impose la famille
nos peuples je suis contre le bloc à
sion vaccinale je ne trouve aucune
raison pour laquelle on doit avoir un
pass à lutter pour accéder aux
établissements au travail au magasin etc
et puis je me demande d'où on a tout cet
argent pour la fabrication de ce vaccin
de me2 multiples vaccin
contre djokovic on attend cet argent
pourquoi on n'a pas trouvé tout cet
argent pour trouver une solution pour le
cancer le premier tueur au monde entier
je suis un docteur en chimie tout les
composés tous les composés de vaccins
sont des composés toxiques pour
l'organisme humain je me demande comment
des médecins peuvent donner un vaccin
qui contient les stedin l'éthanol et
d'autres composés comme les oxydes de
graffer et s'ils peuvent n'importe quel
médecin nous expliquer qu est ce que ça
veut dire un lit posant tout le monde on
va se faire vacciner mais
malheureusement comme l'a dit dr raul
ces questions d'argent c'est pas
question de santé pour les gens un
document qui deviendra obligatoire à
compter du 22 décembre pour se rendre au
cinéma au stade au restaurant ou encore
au musée mais également à l'université
ou tout établissement public y compris
les hôpitaux publics et privés même pour
les accompagnants pour ses opposants au
pass vaccinale qui dénonce une dictature
sanitaires la décision du gouvernement
est illogique au vu de la situation
stable en tunisie il espère se faire
entendre par le tribunal administratif
et le ministère de la santé objectif
pour revenir sur ce décret d'application
rendant obligatoire le passe à lithaire
au guatemala la violence entre
communautés indigènes ne faiblit pas
illustration ce week-end avec un
affrontement entre deux villages au
cours duquel 13 personnes ont été tuées
des terres disputées sont à l'origine de
ce conflit qui dure depuis plus d'un
siècle
un sujet de marion caudal et que l'on
delcourt
très cercueil et une nouvelle agression
c'est le triste bilan d'une attaque ce
week end les victimes se rendaient à une
récolte de maïs lorsqu'ils ont été pris
en embuscade par des hommes armés
[Musique]
la communauté bouleversé les gens sont
tristes espère aussi que cela ne se
reproduira pas parce que chaque jour
nous sommes menacés par cette situation
il monte au sommet et commence à tirer
donc les gens sont dans la peur
c'est ce que nous avons répété ça suffit
ça suffit tout ce qu'on demande c'est
que le gouvernement ne se contente pas
de déclaration parce que c'est tellement
facile de faire une déclaration après
coup il faut venir sur les lieux des
événements et voir de ses propres yeux
la douleur qui est ressenti
dans l'ouest du guatemala
c'est un conflit foncier qui perdure de
villages habités par des communautés
indigènes se disputent des terres depuis
plus d'un siècle
alejandro gars matin le président
guatémaltèque a demandé l'état de siège
suite à une escalade de violence et
réaffirme l'engagement du gouvernement
pour assurer la sécurité
ces événements ne sont plus le produit
d'un conflit foncier ancestrales ils
sont l'oeuvre d'un groupe armé illégal
et organisé qui a agi contre des civils
et des forces de sécurité
en exécutant une embuscade au cours de
laquelle de multiples meurtres d'hommes
de femmes et même d'enfants ont été
commis je veux être catégorique et
assurer aux guatémaltèques que les
forces de l'ordre poursuivront les
responsables de cette attaque jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient arrêtés et traduits en
justice
dans un communiqué publié sur twitter la
police nationale annonce maintenir des
équipes de différentes unités
spécialisées à caractère préventif
communautaire et sécuritaires au
guatemala les communautés indigènes
représentent plus de 40% des 17 millions
d'habitants et beaucoup vivent dans la
pauvreté
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes rester avec nous sur rt france à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts nés sur la bbc insu réalité
hôpital